OF THE TALLAHASSEE
BLACK REPUBLICANS.
NOW, I'M PISSED!
all: MM-HMM.
- ROYALLY PISSED!
- LAST NOVEMBER, BARACK OBAMA
WAS RE-ELECTED PRESIDENT,
AND THE BLACK VOTE
WENT ALMOST ENTIRELY TO HIM!
[crowd murmuring]
- DAGNABBIT.
- WE'RE NOT GETTING
OUR MESSAGE OUT, OBVIOUSLY.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS AND SHOULD BE
THE ONLY HOME FOR BLACK VOTES.
- YES, SIR.
- NOW, PEOPLE THINK THAT
BLACK VOTERS ARE A MONOLITH.
[scoffs]
WE'RE NOT A MONOLITH.
- WHAT? WHAT?
- NO, WE'RE NOT.
- IN FACT,
BLACK REPUBLICANS ALONE
ARE AN EXTREMELY DIVERSE
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
[crowd murmuring agreement]
NOW, TO SPEAK MORE
ON DIVERSITY,
I PRESENT TONIGHT'S SPEAKER,
MR. DOUGLAS JACKSON.
[applause]
[applause ends abruptly]
- NOW, I'M NOT GONNA
SUGARCOAT IT, I'M PISSED!
[crowd murmuring agreement]
I'M ROYALLY PISSED.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA
THINKS THAT REPUBLICANISM
IS NOT FOR BLACK PEOPLE.
all: MM.
- NOW, YOU TELL ME, WHAT
ABOUT FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY,
A STRONG NATIONAL DEFENSE,
AND A LIMITED GOVERNMENT
IS UNAPPEALING
TO BLACK PEOPLE?
WE'RE NOT A MONOLITH!
all: MM-MMM.
- WE COME IN ALL DIFFERENT
SHAPES AND SIZES.
- WE DO.
all: MM-HMM!
- NOW, WHO HERE WOULD LIKE
TO COME UP TO THIS PODIUM
AND SPEAK ABOUT THE DIVERSITY
AMONGST BLACK REPUBLICANS?
- [clears throat]
- OH.
[chuckles]
GENTLEMEN,
WE HAVE A REAL TREAT TODAY,
A GENTLEMAN
WHO IS A LITTLE BIT ECCENTRIC,
A LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE OF THE BOX,
IF YOU WILL,
BUT I CAN'T THINK
OF A BETTER PERSON TO SPEAK
ON DIVERSITY
AMONGST BLACK REPUBLICANS
THAN THIS GENTLEMAN
RIGHT HERE.
ALL THE WAY FROM ORLANDO,
MY GOOD FRIEND,
ARTHUR WASHINGTON!
[applause]
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, MAN.
[applause]
[applause ends abruptly]
- THANK YOU
FOR THE INTRODUCTION,
BROTHER DOUGLAS.
- THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
BROTHER ARTHUR.
- MM-HMM.
HOWEVER, I AM...
PISSED.
[crowd murmuring agreement]
ROYALLY PISSED.
- INDEED, INDEED!
- ALL RIGHT.
- DEMOCRATS THINK
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO ALL THE BLACK PEOPLE.
BUT THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
WE ARE NOT A MONOLITH.
[crowd murmuring agreement]
DEMOCRATS MAY BE COOL,
BUT THEY AIN'T PRACTICAL.
- THERE YOU GO.
[crowd murmuring agreement]
- REPUBLICANS
ARE PRACTICAL.
BLACK PEOPLE
ARE PRACTICAL!
COME TO THINK OF IT...
- GET THOSE PANTS.
- I THINK BLACK REPUBLICANS
ARE PRETTY COOL.
[crowd murmuring agreement]
- HEAR, HEAR, HEAR, HEAR.
- NOT TO MENTION
VERY DIVERSE.
- THERE WE GO. MM-HMM.
[door opens]
- EXCUSE ME, GENTLEMEN.
SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
SOMEONE'S WHITE WIFE
IS HERE TO PICK THEM UP.
[all murmuring]
- WAS HER NAME EMILY?
- UH, SHE WAS WHITE.
- OH, GREAT, THAT'S--